bindi Irwin is all grown up and nearly
unrecognizable in her latest selfie it's
hard to believe that bindi turns 18 next
month the Norley baby-faced are
experimenting with makeup on Instagram
Thursday and look super glamorous the 17
year old wildlife enthusiast shared this
pic in full glam including some gorgeous
waves in her hair
yes bindi got done up for Dancing with
the Stars but overall we're used to
seeing her own natural while exploring
the outdoors and we are loving this more
mature look on bindi though she's still
her low-key self look at bindi in this
cute snap with her mom and brother
posted the same day she captioned it
family photos we just can't seem to
stand still and if anyone's crushing on
adorable bindi a reminder she's taken
bindi dates her longtime boyfriend
Chandler Powell Chandler is one of the
kindest people I've ever known
which is really fantastic he's a very
patient person and just loves wildlife
and conservation and it's great to be
able to find somebody who shares the
same values